[Music]
New York City home to thousands of
restaurants the most competitive city in
the world but there's one restaurant
that needs my help more than any other
and it's right down there
the night on Kitchen Nightmares New York
City may be the mecca of fine dining but
in the heart of Manhattan is a
restaurant in such bad shape it may
prove to be Gordon's biggest challenge
yet oh my God Dillons an Indian Eatery
is not on the verge of disaster what do
we need a death in the restaurant before
some gets a grip it's already
there it's rotten my man the menu is
confusing British Italian anything is
not on here it's Chinese the food is
awful green Burgers kill people there is
a language barrier tell him in your
language you'll kill somebody and as far
as the cleanliness goes holy oh my
God it's not a pretty sight and what
makes matters worse the numerous
managers don't seem to care I have
nothing to be guilty of you what no one
is getting served from this
Russian tonight get ready to witness one
crazy week in the life of Gordon Ramsay
this is the luckiest
mess can you go and tell them that the
kitchen is closed tonight on Kitchen
Nightmares
foreign
[Music]
yes Lisa how are you with Dylan's this
is an American Irish restaurant with an
Indian
nurse connected to it
[Music]
it's hard for me to believe that Dylan's
has lasted this long okay and you had
eight people leave on you yes we kind of
lurched between catastrophe and disaster
my wife my family we started this
restaurant to make a new life but the
restaurant is not doing that well Dylan
good evening how can I help you I hired
Martin to take care of this business
I had an objective the idea was to
capture the best of all worlds where are
we choosing from we have beef Buna which
menu Lamb Chop shepherd's pie that's the
waves of the future hamburgers
I think people are a bit confused as to
like what kind of restaurant this is
I don't know what each manager does
specifically
I'm the general manager I'm the
operations manager and I'm a floor
manager here
nobody really knew Khan was a manager he
doesn't do anything yet I don't like to
work here because everything's so messed
up
I think in an Ideal World Martin would
be an ongoing character in a reality TV
series
my responsibilities include an awful lot
of things I make sure that everything
runs
something's broken I fix it I make sure
that there's toilet paper to wipe your
butt with
frequently I will have to cook something
because the cooks who make the Indian
food
don't know how to make American food
if we get customers in here I will walk
up to table serve them their food and
they'll be sliding flies away okay it is
disgusting
the kitchen is not clean
the problem has been eradicated now I
think it has
oh there's a flight
for last six months we are lodging like
20 to 30 000 a month I cannot continue
losing money like this I don't want to
continue with this nightmare I'll do
anything and everything what Gordon
Ramsay asked me to do to make this place
as successful
[Music]
technically Gordon's successful New York
restaurant is only two blocks away from
this kitchen nightmare
[Music]
all taped out and what the is that
sign there like a scoreboard
[Music]
hello Gordon Ramsay Martin general
manager this is Dylan's Indian
restaurant Indian restaurant yes it
doesn't sound like an Indian does it
no no Dylan's no when I first met Gordon
I seem to be a fairly intimidating guy
and that's exactly what he was Mohammed
Islam the owner of the place Mohammed
how are you fine thank you hello Jenna
Jenna nice to see you Gordon definitely
has a presence about him
[Music]
or just relax and go with everything
this is another operation manager
general manager operation manager yes I
have one Rocky table trust you to pick
the worst table in the house let's sit
this table shall we yeah okay good
[Music]
um
uh Martin yes um we're such a huge menu
am I writing thing there's two kitchens
there's two different chefs in one
kitchen they work alongside each other
British Italian Buffalo yes anything is
not on here it's Chinese
are you normally this busy for lunch oh
actually it's a little busy today
we don't have people coming in because
they've seen empty
sometimes I don't get a table at all
from the main menu assorted vegetarians
appetizers and then for me course the
lamb Biryani and beef Buna from the
American menu I'll go for the salmon
please thank you you're welcome
[Music]
I need the appetizers first are you okay
I'm quite excited to see the reaction
look like great service great food so
it's a win-win situation the rules are
counseling looks like it's been
plastered with Hospital linen that's
where the customers go after they come
out this restaurant
of course there's no salmon why
would there be salmon when
Gordon Ramsay ordered his lunch he must
have looked into a crystal ball
because he orders something that we
didn't have let me just make sure that I
can order something that they don't have
[Music]
Frozen fish
or a great chef
right
there's two fritters those ones well
with our vegetable they're both
vegetable yes may the Lord above not
poison me oh man
in terms of beauty it's not exactly an
Indian classic is it it looks like it's
a dehydrated turd
[Music]
there's meat in there
that one's got meat in there
if he were a vegetarian I would expect a
lawsuit it's gonna be fun to ask them
about
you guys are killing me right now the
assorted a vegetarian appetizer plate
has to be vegetarian okay vegetarian he
just had a meat one
word the West is over all right
beef Puna
would you uh would you mind getting me a
clean one please
what the is that always worries me
when I stick tomato roses
food and the tomato is rotten
[Music]
that is not a piece of beef
does that look like a piece of beef to
you my darling it's dry it looks like
pork now that's beef then I I was born
in Bangladesh
Gomez he says to try this it's pork
pretty sure it's pork the beef
yeah it was lamb so now it was lamb
Gordon didn't seem to enjoy much of
anything and that's how it usually goes
with customers where did you start on
this one
Martin they look like they were cooked
at least a week ago well that's good and
frozen salmon too Andy that's good you
have come to the rescue once again one
of the greatest chefs in the world wants
something to eat and I had to make it
thank you
so this is from the American Kitchen
looks like a doormat another fly
huh is this normal
um yes it is who made this
um I did so you're the operations
manager you're yes the chef as well yes
we haven't got any other chefs in the
back that can cook this food they don't
know how to cook any western style food
can you do me a favor yes
either
that was pleasure pretty much everything
that could go wrong went horribly and
catastrophically wrong oh God
[Music]
tell us juice yeah pleased to meet you
Gordon tell him in a really nice way
yeah your food is
food glands old-fashioned I've eaten it
I don't feel too good
but it says that that lamb is probably
the old lamb you serve me old lamb I
embarrassed to see the situations
they get a little nervous as they made a
mistake in there made a mistake
maybe they stand that Gordon has a very
high compared to mine I didn't expect
it's gonna go that bad
[Music]
coming up Gordon's nightmares are
realized that is poison as he takes a
look inside this kitchen green Burgers
kill people will Andrew and Martin
survive the night I've never met a
general manager so as you and later
what filth will Gordon find lurking
below oh my God what do we need a death
in the restaurant before some
gets a grip that's coming up our Kitchen
Nightmares
[Music]
after Gordon's lunchtime Fiasco he now
tries to understand how this restaurant
is managed I'm not worthy of sparkling
water tap water here
are we going to reset this table eeny
meeny miny mo cancer manager by the toe
you are watching you're the floor
manager
holy mackerel when I came to work I was
nervous but at the same time I was happy
because I had a chance to work with Chef
frenzy that's why you're here
the place you think is that funny and
easy to do
everybody here hates Khan and I can't
fire the guy because he's protected by
Muhammad now we have a floor manager
operations manager and channel manager
I was resting just thinking of various
things I've got to sort out one of the
waitresses was rubbing my hair it was a
natural thing how many managers did this
place need I found a new manager we now
have a floor manager and amongst the
operations manager there's managed by
the general manager three
managers and they're all
oh dear
with a better understanding of the staff
structure it's time for Gordon to see
the staff in action at a dinner service
welcome nice to see you all
are you still looking over the menu well
we're just sort of debating whether we
wanted something on the American side
the Indian's very good where are we
choosing from which menu it's also
becoming clear to Gordon that the
multiple styles of menu is not a
positive but a negative
yeah
okay you ready
okay
oh holy Moses
[Music]
lift it off the floor and don't put it
on the floor hello Madam floor manager
operations manager general manager
anybody
mommy can you explain to Gomez yes yeah
that we've got to stop putting things on
the floor
it's unhygienic I'm hygienic and it
could be dangerous too it's very
dangerous yes
it's 40 minutes into the service and
unbelievably no food has left the
kitchen my first table still hasn't
gotten her entree
one of the major reasons for the delay
kitchen chaos
[Music]
who's in charge here I'm taking over
Expediting here you're Expediting yes
Mohammed what are you doing in here I'm
trying to help them up you've got three
managers Two Chefs eight girls out the
front and no one can delegate oh
my God okay kids one order of salmon
left one salmon special let everybody
know and when the information is shouted
from the kitchen Martin is busy again
not with customers but with his phone oh
my God okay that has to be ready before
this goes up
ultimately Martin doesn't belong in a
leadership position the measure on the
floor to do something about it this
place this plate running in chaos it's
totally dysfunctional and there needs to
be leadership here so what are you
cooking tonight
nothing nothing at all
getting the general manager Martin
please all right
Martin
Gordon Ramsay was really getting under
my scheme
okay right
um this young man's here he's standing
here and he has nothing to cook is this
how you run a place no no I don't want a
place like this all right why did it
take me to let you know that he's
standing there playing with radishes
because
um you're busy
that's a horrible thing to say but I was
busy in the front there yes
he was alluding to my relationship with
the waitresses yeah you get off on it
girl stroke in your hair massaging your
ego
you're such a fake I'm not fake I'm just
why why are you saying on the fight
you've got members of your team standing
here getting paid doing off I've
never met a general manager so as
you
okay if this was your money would you
let him stand here playing with a stick
that's what you're doing here isn't it
you're riding Muhammad you know you're
Skilling that poor man yes you
are you're taking advantage of a weak
rich man that's what's just
clicked in my mind and he got personal
he was accusing me of riding Muhammad
this type of thing and that got me
because how the hell if you got the
right to say something to me they didn't
even know me we got more staff than
customers tonight and we still can't get
a ride
[Music]
an hour and a half into dinner service
and only a few dishes have made their
way to customers who are not exactly
thrilled with Dylan's dining experience
thank you very much
who haven't received food are getting
ready to leave two minutes we're leaving
and you know we asked like seriously two
minutes what else I can do for you right
now so that'll make you happy
I'm sorry ladies or I can discount your
bill thank you
[Music]
thank you
it's day two and Gordon has already been
appalled by the food and dismayed by the
inadequate management
I do the thing I've been dreading most
yeah getting into the kitchen I am not
looking forward to this part
when were these changed last
um
well at least the Flies float fresh oh
my gosh I have no idea why is the Flies
there is a lot of flies here
[Music]
[Applause]
what is that
you don't know
I've ever seen in my entire life
oh my God these were my potatoes
for lunch
you do me a favor yes either
[Music]
thank God I sat a little down to
eat them that's not a potato green
chicken
what goes on down here
[Applause]
[Music]
for God's sake
look at that
whoa
cockroaches
holy
foreign
oh my God that is the worst hamburger
I've ever seen in my entire life having
discovered the terrible conditions in
the kitchen Gordon now Ventures down to
the basement of the restaurant to check
out what's lurking below
[Music]
so we have got rats here
[Applause]
jack is all over the place
[Music]
there's rat droppings look at them all
everywhere that's right
oh my good God look at the Cockroaches
oh my god look I got one in my
hair it's cockroaches boxes full of them
look
look at them all
oh my god look there they are there in
refrigeration
oh it no oh my God
oh no
look at that
oh my God look at them
there you go
there you go I was shocked it's like a
nightmare look damn it I mean it's it's
not even a pepper it's rotten and I'm
worried about the flies in the dying
room I know where they're
breeding now look at it
I've eaten here come on
Martin
uh we all miss you hopefully see you
soon take care bye
okay yeah I need Martin urgently he's a
gentleman yes yeah good you're you're
needed right now I'm leaving right now
yes needed in the kitchen urgently are
you in charge of this are you
responsible for this
that is the salad I had lunch time it's
opened the bag and bang out comes the
Flies uh gentlemen it gets worse than
that
it's green
it's beyond edible it's disgusting look
at the color of those chicken wings
everything in
in the putrid how long has that been in
there
kill somebody
we're not passing the buck but I know my
general manager knows what the
going on in my fridges where are your
standards
standards look at it
let me just tell you something I've
eaten here
where's that from that's been sliced
that's gone out what is that where is it
hey Madam where's that tomato gone
it's rotten you idiot
[Music]
as a customer just being served a slice
of tomato
where is it oh my God
[Music]
things are looking pretty glum
what do we need a death in the
restaurant before some gets a
grip
how many tables are out there there's
three three you tell those three tables
this is the luckiest there they're
live okay
the only thing worse than having tables
sent away is knowing that well I was
going to serve them could make them sick
one is getting served on this
mission tonight let's make that clear
yes or no
anyone against that no no good that
didn't go down too well he was extremely
angry extremely pissed off we are not
[Music]
eating any of this food I don't give a
what anyone says can you go and
tell them that the kitchen is closed
right now out there and telling the
truth tell them now Gordon was so
outraged so angry
I've never seen anything like it one
green Burgers the furry cucumber
the crunchy potatoes
I'm sorry to inform you that we are not
going to be serving dinner this evening
Chef Ramsay's shut down the kitchen
it's just disgraceful I feel terrible
that it's gotten to this point
I'm speechless
it is a nightmare this is so horrible I
should close down this place this is
worse than a nightmare
[Music]
foreign
Gordon has encountered one of the most
disgusting kitchens he has ever seen oh
my God and so he must take Serious
action
let's go us
all these guys to know I mean
business
clean means a proper clean
[Music]
New Jersey little where are you
I was just looking at him
and thinking
okay once I'm clean I mean clean yeah
guys
let's go
these guys are professional steam
cleaners yeah
this is straight through there
cleaners it was cleaners Plus
addressed like people from Star Wars
I've got to say
and you guys are doing it with them yeah
oh God
[Music]
phase one of Gordon's mission to seek
out and destroy all moldy rotten and
contaminated Foods we're gonna work
today the next phase of operation
sterilize steam clean every square inch
of the kitchen
[Music]
now it's time to Enlighten Muhammad and
his managers with a little trip a couple
of blocks away to the kitchen of
Gordon's New York restaurant okay I want
to show you something
the difference between night and day
this is a kitchen
have a look around
[Music]
all kitchens should be like this
Gordon's kitchen is absolutely
spectacular no matter what size
restaurant you are you can keep a clean
shop and you can keep it organized open
the fridge door Martin
we went to the London that was a walk of
shame twice a day these fridges are
cleaned
this is heaven that was hell
[Music]
in order to reach out to the local
Indian Community and New Yorkers at
large Gordon has come up with his
strategy for the menu Contemporary
Indian Cuisine does he know we're in
Broadway where are we New Jersey New
Jersey oh me well yeah he doesn't
even know we're in New York we
are in New York restaurant right with
the salmon we're gonna make a bit of a
broth right coconut and tomatoes and
onions right the secret behind the
scallop is nice and pink it's sweet a
little bit of curry powder yes yes and
then from there just set it on top of
the chutney
pan said scallops are Walnut Chutney
wonderful crispy salmon with a tomato
coconut curry broth just opened my eyes
to what can be done cleaned modern way
to serve Indian food very good look at
me oh Jesus give me a cuddle out
okay very very good
tell him he's only a scallop yeah we
haven't lost our children okay okay you
can let go now I can let go now
you cannot go now I did okay
[Music]
to help execute Gordon's menu makeover
he has Enlisted the help of one of the
top Indian chefs in New York City vikas
Khanna good to see you buddy are you
welcome I need you here to work with the
team of chefs and to get this place back
on the map yeah it's beautiful location
we're in the heart of Manhattan we can
do it here
thank you
later in the night Gordon's design team
is brought in to dramatically transform
the restaurant's interior and exterior
[Music]
new day the tacky electronic sign is
being removed and the restaurant is
given an authentic Indian name poornima
which means full moon let's go here we
go there we are all blindfolded much to
our shagwin I'll tell you okay on the
count of three take off your blindfolds
one
two
three
welcome wow
haven't they done an amazing job great
job amazing job moment have a look from
down here it's like now you're feeling
wow what a difference isn't it beautiful
beautiful it has a nice clean crisp look
it looks now like it's been done by
professionals the way it should oh wow
this is beautiful isn't it lovely I'm
happy to come into work now and not see
the material
it's so much more than I thought it'd be
new chairs new bonquette new linen new
pictures and it looks like something
that is classic yes he just turned this
restaurant from zero to hundred we're
gonna go outside let's have a quick look
outside
[Music]
wow wow wow
everything
stand back a little bit there's no
confusion the color's beautiful yes I'm
not gonna miss that sign
so glad to have it gone it looks like a
real restaurant again the amazing job
after working through the night vicas is
ready to present the new menu he
designed with Gordon the old menu has
been replaced with classic Indian dishes
that have a modern twist everything is
done very simple according to American
palette I didn't know that Indian food
like that exists
except Kerala Fisherman's Curry okay
that's a very basic Curry we move to the
next test we have kadai shrimp here
after the trio we have the chicken korma
we are using saffron a real saffron for
this flavor Mr vikas is so cute he is a
magician to me
and green Garden's recipe of saffron
cauliflower
Flex these
these bath freshness and food vibrant
flavors and it's very approachable for
everyone
[Music]
today core all in good shape it's time
for Gordon to turn his attention back to
the staff big big night yes this place
is about to be relaunched properly
tonight it has to work okay what's your
role for tonight general manager I'm in
front of house I'll be meeting greetings
would you do me a favor when the
customer sit down when you're not sort
of be so false when you jump on just
sometimes I feel it's so in your face
it's intimidating for them okay yeah
yeah watching your performance all the
time
tacky will you promise to keep your
phone off in the middle of service
[Music]
must be attentive to staff needs when
necessary yeah will you attempt to act
as a general manager for the first time
ever stepping into this business
take it as your Cafe and hangout area
[Music]
that is a great morale booster before
the opening of this amazing new
restaurant
will you actually treat it as a business
if you could try to make some
improvement this evening please
Martin he is not qualified for a GM I
don't see the confidence that he need
Martin's not full of okay you're
giving him such a hard time and it's
making me angry I'm frustrated for the
lack of respect this man has that's with
him not with you so would you mind
keeping your nose out of my business
don't try and interrupt me
excuse me this is a loyal worker no I'm
sorry you don't need your minion to try
and convince me how good you are on the
back of what I've experienced is that
clear imagine please Garden helped us to
achieve that one it's an amazing job yes
yes prove ourselves we do the job right
absolutely definitely and then we see
this Garden we did it thank you Muhammad
I've been waiting for that for the last
week I'm really pleased that it came out
so now I want to see positivity from
everybody absolutely everybody if
there's anyone who doesn't think they
can pull on the Rope like that look for
a new job
[Music]
it's the morning of relaunch and Gordon
has organized a plan to spread the word
in Manhattan it's a purnima parade look
at that
[Music]
wow what a brilliant idea uh promoting
purnima restaurant off we go I will jump
on yes
my girls music Santa promoting ideas all
of them I love
[Music]
it was nice to be able to do something
together we needed that more than
anything because I think all of our
Spirits were so broken
[Music]
all of a sudden you've all come alive my
God
it's only two hours to go until the
doors open and the restaurant is booking
up the future of purnima rests greatly
on tonight's reopening for
Muhammad tonight is a golden opportunity
but he needs his staff to rise to the
occasion
good evening I would say this table
right here I've got a table right here
for you
it is very exciting to see these
restaurants full again the kitchen is
under the strong leadership of vikas so
he's going to bring but Gordon will be
keeping an eye on the general manager
Martin advertisers everybody take some
time the success of phone number depends
on the teamwork that's the crucial point
of running purnima uh Martin yep give me
the phone
thank you
is it on it's on it's off
okay yes sir you ready for order
[Music]
this is the new Star for prelima new
Decor new menu contemporary fresh and
how exciting it's all fresh all new and
wonderful everything's just going
perfectly well but
[Music]
customers are responding well to the new
menu and the first wave of orders is now
hitting the kitchen
I need one Lamb Chop medium
piping hot please take this take this
[Music]
we've got tons and customers tonight
we've got a turntables yeah
but as the orders start to Pile in
Martin's lack of managerial skills start
to show
that they want the lamb
the ladies that yeah and the weight
staff becomes confused
can somebody take this place which is
causing disorder in the kitchen and
everything is starting to back up Martin
Khan the food's sitting here no one's
moving their ass yes it's getting cold
and cold and cold
[Music]
happened I need another race please so
Jimmy Martin please yeah quickly yeah
[Music]
everyone's standing in a Donna can you
get out the rice please
[Music]
Martin could you sweep the rice then
we're out there we're selling it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah be nice to do
something yeah so we don't have to send
more food to the rats that's great
finally found a job
even on a night with a top chef at the
helm Martin's mismanagement of his
waders has caused problems in the
kitchen and the customers are paying the
price
about it's cold and a lot of Autumn and
I'm surprised
warm it's a nightmare
okay we're now just starting to turn
these first tables but Panic setting
customers are complaining about food
being cold
and these staff are not used to being
busy especially like this
oh yeah let's go race it was cold
because it's lying around just
take this please service please
I never served as many customers before
who's running the restaurant Martin
somebody ordered this 33. I'm not gonna
say anything negative about the
restaurant but I don't understand this
restaurant let's go oh there you go
rather than a big tray right where you
going what table
what was that for Bacchus
Bacchus features I don't think that that
Martin understands what a general
manager really should be doing don't
make any phone calls along the way
straight to the table
why is that Rice going cold now why
doesn't it be served successive learning
yes it's actually burning I want the
customer to experience it hot not your
hand customers are complaining about the
food cold my man
foreign
or whatever and I wasn't taking any part
with that
Gordon has seen enough of Martin's
managerial incompetence and believes he
may have found a solution be honest with
me can you manage this place yes so stop
blending in and stand on your feet
okay yes I can do that I will try my
best to convince Chef Ramsay that I can
run this restaurant
ready guys ready everything is ready
[Music]
that's okay that's okay relax with Khan
taking the reins food is finally making
it out to the customers
[Music]
for the water use the tray take it to
the down there each other table 44 need
their all checked
with Khan in the dining room and vikas
in the kitchen the restaurant is
beginning to run smoothly it was a very
very good expense for me and my whole
team and then make me feel good one two
three
tonight I made over a hundred dollars I
was so happy make sure you guys come
back again okay take care
[Music]
the grand opening of purnima was bumpy
in the middle but finished on a high
note where would you please however
Gordon knows his work is not done
this place can be phenomenal the
location is extraordinary this is a new
start you have to treat it as a new
beginning of course I mean in a perfect
world I would sacrifice one of your
managers to employ vikas
you cannot carry Driftwood in your
business
out of the three managers
one has to go
[Music]
between you and I Martin has an amazing
way of manipulating you and he is not
worth his weight in terms of what he
brings to the table here in Gordon
Ramsay so that to Muhammad and that
makes me upset and angry the frustration
just boiled over tonight yeah I've never
used who I've expected to I'm proud of
what we've done I've never cheated
you
[Music]
I'm giving you passion this person I've
expected and you've had the audacity to
accuse me of like taking his mind and
off his back riding off his back is is
what you've said well that is disgusting
you have no right you don't know that
whatever whatever you have nothing to be
guilty of
he was nothing you sat in it it's rotten
yeah you ran it you sat in it yes you
wasted it yes I wasted it you encouraged
it
it's always like this we it is
not guilty
[Music]
you have nothing to be guilty of
what nothing you sat in it yeah you ran
it you sat in it yes you wasted it yes I
wasted it you encouraged it
not guilty I'm not going to take this
put down anymore and nothing to be
guilty of listen this is my last night
and you said it was last night yes yes
listen you're staying tonight
okay please tell the owner not me this
is my last night I'm out of here I quit
[Music]
Jesus Christ when Martin left actually
I'm very shock I didn't expect it's
going to go that bad
I think Gordon Ramsay is full of his and
I'm extremely angry extremely pissed off
and I now turn my back and walk away
[Music]
with the success of the relaunch and the
change of management for Nema has beaten
the odds and is now looking to a bright
future
in the following days purnima's
Contemporary Indian food and atmosphere
continued to generate great Buzz
throughout New York City
the restaurant's Revenue increased and
naturally so did the service tips thank
you thank you so much and Chef vikas
accepted an offer from Muhammad to be
the restaurant's ongoing consultant are
you at any limit at any extent thanks a
lot I appreciate it thank you so much
let's be honest it's gone exceptionally
well yes yes yes
free food great Decor great Buzz happy
customers I really mean it thank you
bloody good job
I'm very happy with the changes Gordon
has made here he has given this place an
opportunity to thrive and be a real
restaurant well all of us over here I
thank you very very much listen you're
very welcome you've got all the tools
now do it don't stop working hard Gordon
did what I thought was completely
impossible with the restaurant
calm my experience with chip Garden was
wonderful I get the coffee that we can
run this business and we can run this
place successfully okay
[Applause]
yes next time I'm coming to eat I'm not
coming to work yes okay yes
I like to thank Chef Ramsay to being a
part of this great success before I
thought it's crazy but he said no it was
a very passionate man I like that very
much
indeed thank you thank you
[Applause]
oh what a transformation I honestly
didn't think we could turn this around
to this extent from what I saw my first
day here my God
for the past three years Gordon Ramsay
has been trying to rescue some of the
worst restaurants in Britain this is
disgusting we have a poor movie let's
not cook this raw
if you don't break away from the stove I
swear to God the business is going to
close I don't think you can actually
cook
no he's traveling to the USA to turn
around America's Kitchen Nightmares
please help me each week he will go to
restaurants on the brink of disaster
there is no more money he's not doing
his job this place is a disaster Zone
I've put so much into it and to get
these restaurants back on track Gordon
will hold nothing back but never ever
ever ever
met someone
I believe in as little as you it's
intense touch a wall you dirty Pig what
do we need a death in the restaurant
before some gets the grip I
thought your food was crap I rather have
this conversation downstairs it's
emotional
oh my God look at them
I've eaten it I've been like spitting
out both of them I think this place will
run better without you can you go and
tell them that the kitchen is closed
we're short it's the luckiest day of
their lives we're shirt for the night
we will make this a success put your
hand up and swear to God in the end
Gordon will bring about dramatic
turnarounds
not just of the restaurants
but of the people who work in them
but while most appreciate Gordon's
Health God bless you you are a wonderful
person others aren't quite so great Jeff
I know you can hear me don't run why is
this guy here
turn around and tell me when you were
like a pig you're French Pig goodbye
Chef good luck loser
get ready as Gordon Ramsay attempts to
turn America's Kitchen Nightmares
receive may the Lord not kill me with
food poisoning but
into dreams please do not screw it up
tonight on Kitchen Nightmares USA Gordon
heads to an old Italian Eatery well this
one's gonna be interesting isn't it to
find a family and a restaurant in crisis
you can become famous in the next 24
hours for poisoning half of
Babylon Tina the owner is a wreck I want
to cry or commit bloody murder and her
brother doesn't seem to care instead of
buying a stove I bought a suit you know
he's a 250 pound spoiled baby you ain't
got me scared you ain't got me skip
with just a week to turn it around
Gordon must pull this family together
but it will be an immense challenge
the chef's worn down when the
dishes are ready that's when they're
gonna come out and the kitchen's worn
out I cannot believe you work in that
this is my one working loving
that's it the manager is a tyrant
and the staff are ready to throw in the
toe
Van Gordon unite this dysfunctional
family restaurant I'm gonna kill myself
this is ridiculous should I come back
next week for the bait Clans and get
their house back in order
[Music]
Babylon New York is a quaint Village on
the southern Shore of Long Island it's
home to a number of Italian restaurants
but there's one family establishment
that needs Gordon Ramsay's help more
than any other
Hi how are you I'm the owner of this
restaurant Peters there's a lot of
stress this place is a mess I'm
all over the place it's pretty open
right now what would you like no one
thinks I'm the owner in here they all
think it's my brother because he's the
host
come on Peter help yeah
there were a lot of restaurant owners
that are married to their business day
and night but I choose not to live my
life that way I'm the only son that's me
I don't really know who Peter thinks he
is
honestly I think he's hoping for a shot
at it the next Goodfellas movie
this is what I thought I was out they
pulled me back in that was a great movie
right yeah
we're close family
we're a close family it's a family
business you understand
I believe Peter is a core problem of the
restaurant
I'm passionate I'm Italian I yell why is
this guy here two minutes later I'm over
it come on let me hug it out let's hug
it out let's hug it out
and he takes advantage of the place can
I have a cappuccino from here please I
take so much pride in myself my
appearance my car my clothes so I got
sauce on my suit I take care of myself
and it shows you can put your hands on
all right
he's not so concerned with the customer
he's more concerned with them noticing
him
instead of buying a stove I bought a
suit you know
the tools that we have in the kitchen
right now need to be sharpened
there are three ovens down the oven on
the bottom is completely out we have a
broiler that's not working
when I got dressed tonight I felt like I
should have been in Florida the whole
family's throwing everything on Tina's
shoulders and I don't think she can
handle okay I don't give
if it broke by
goddamn candle holder
this restaurant was one of the top
restaurants in the village here and uh
it's just really slowly decline the
restaurant is not making the money that
it was making right now we're not paying
the bills do me a favor go take a walk
how's that go take a walk we're
getting phone calls the guy has not stop
calling and my father's making this
situation worse I feel that my business
is at a pivotal point it keeps me up at
night but I know there are problems here
you made a big mistake Josh yeah before
I lose my life I would sell the place
and I don't want to do that that's not
in my heart
thank you
I'm here in Babylon in New York to meet
Peter from Peter's restaurant it's a
family small Quaint restaurant and it's
on its ass struggling big time and he
said he's gonna pick me up
where is he
come on
this can't be him
what the is this
Peter how you doing Gordon good to see
you nice car how are you yeah welcome to
Babylon yeah how are you very well
thanking you good great yeah you look
well yeah thank you so do you from the
minute we met it was like Superman
arrived you know so I'm very excited
come on in I feel like I'm in Hollywood
and what a quaint little uh town so here
it is
welcome theaters thank you FDO
I want to introduce you to my family mom
dad this is Gordon Ramsay and this is
Cena
when I first met him like you know I
don't know how to take them but look
this hair like that I think he's one of
these
crazy foreigners is your restaurant
Peters it's my name yeah it's mine how
nice all the family working together
yeah absolutely mum dad Big Brother
little sister when Gordon got here I was
so looking forward to meeting him I mean
he's a smart guy he's a good looking guy
he's charismatic so who's the chef
Robert Robert Gordon Ramsay how are you
this pleasure this is Robin or Sarah and
you're the head chef I'm the head chef
excellent these are my two best friends
Joey and Joey Jerry and Joey yeah
curious oh you know what it is if they
don't like the food Jerry and Jerry
picks the out of them I feel
honored I've been introduced to the Mob
well this one's gonna be interesting
isn't it me
we decided yeah I might start with the
crab cake cupcakes thank you okay and
then one of my favorites Lobster ravioli
very good lovely
thank you I'm sorry your first name was
Angelo Angela gentlemen I got uh
Ramsay's order please
[Music]
excuse me thank you okay this is a spicy
Dijon sauce the cafe is homemade they're
homemade yes thank you enjoy
looks terrible to sell it
foreign
how old is that salad take it back
before something jumps out of there I'll
just taste the crab cake and I mean it's
rotten that no yes damn this is
ridiculous man look at the how old is
this salad you make me look like a
um Angelo yes I don't want to put you in
an awkward position but that's stone
cold in the middle and that's not fresh
crab meat that gross okay I'll let him
know yeah
when you come into an Italian restaurant
you want to identify that the food is
fresh instantly crab cake cold
not a good start
he might knock the ravioli he's gonna
knock the ravioli where's he Gonna Knock
about the ravioli he said good no yeah
from Restaurant Depot what do you think
yeah
[Music]
thank you well I don't need any parsley
that's not even Lobster that's just like
baby food inside Gunk well Paul garnish
that dish what who garnished that dish
you got to be kidding me you put half a
pound of parsley on my plate he said wow
enough parsley on this dish first of all
I put the pasta on that's my job and
I'll decide what goes on it it ain't
your problem yeah but I don't need to
hear criticism which I already know
John did it go yell it in
it's craziness it's chaos at times I can
shoot every person in here
John the sous chef is insulted over the
parsley
I'm gonna go diffuse a fight in this
kitchen right now excuse me
do you understand what I'm saying Angelo
all the time holy smoke welcome
to Babylon
now that Gordon has tried the food it's
time for a heart to heart with a
Pellegrino family I'd like to be told
the truth nothing but the truth and the
quicker I get to the truth the quicker I
can help so
manager the way I look at things is
everyone needs to have a job come in
comes in tells everyone my role
including don't overseeing what goes on
he wants coffee he wants Awards
he knows
but you're here you know but you really
shouldn't give him point of anything he
comes here and creates more problems
coming up always fascinating what you
find at the back of the fridge Gordon's
shocking kitchen investigation looks
like something I have a sci-fi movie
leads to a confrontation with the family
you can become famous in the next 24
hours poison half of Avalon will
Gordon and Peter ever see eye to eye you
this place will run better without you
or will Peter continue to wreak havoc on
his restaurant you blogger
[Music]
it's day two in Babylon and Gordon has
already discovered that the specialty of
this restaurant is arguing now it's time
to investigate the state of the kitchen
what is in there
where's rolls bread rocks temperature of
the fridge is not even cold so it says
rotten mold moldy Decay rotten onions
yeah they look like camel's turd
it looks like something I have a
sci-fi movie
oh my God
did you eat that it's like the fridge
has dripped all over it the whole
thing's leaking here last year's rain
water inside our thing looks like it's
about to fall down
[Music]
what happened I had to pick up something
that came indirectly to you know
inadvertently to the wrong place this
was like an act of God this morning
let me show you something that I hope
will open your eyes
um Tina Angelo as well yeah have a look
at this when was the last time you went
inside a walk-in fridge to walk in
fridge yeah uh I had a hot flash last
week I think a hot flash what does that
mean I mean it was like hot and I walked
in here for a second
what the look there's onions grown
on top of onions but it gets worse
unfortunately the whole thing's leaking
here what the is that what is that
I don't know you have taste of Chef you
can become famous in the next 24 hours
for poisoning half of Babylon
you ought to be ashamed that is
sour and has to be four weeks old just
just just smell that for me no no just
just smell it I just give it up yeah
okay just just smell it though Tina
would we really serve that
does it just fall under the chef's job
well where are the this is your
fridge
can we get out of here before I catch
something yeah I feel terrible it's like
you know telling somebody telling you
your kid is ugly
the walking box is a mess but you know
what that walking box was exactly how we
felt about working in the kitchen it's
like blame everything on me and
guys please clean the place you
embarrassing me I've never seen
something like this this is unbelievable
before Gordon does anything else he
wants to make sure the kitchen is
spotless
how we doing ladies
I believe Peter is a core problem of the
restaurants dysfunction and he isn't
concerned much about anybody else but
himself
[Music]
chin is no cleaner than it's been in
years so Gordon can turn his attention
to observing tonight's dinner service
and reservations what we got books we're
really uh what do we have some
there's nothing in there
is rough it's hurting I may have to sell
my watch you got twenty dollars so it's
fake
the only thing as fake is my teeth
they're wines they're white
they're bleached how much that cost
a thousand to visit
I just brushed mine twice a day
okay now but it goes well with a brown
tan
well you know somewhat yeah I'd rather
buy a new stove
it's been such a long time
since I have good equipment here it's
bothering me but there's nothing I can
do about it it's not my restaurant what
doesn't work all these stove tops here
don't work
the broiler doesn't work proper this
oven does not work we use it as storage
we keep our towels and stuff in here
when was the last time a new piece of
equipment was bought in this kitchen
yeah they never put a nickel into this
place pizza is a lot more proud of his
car than he is his restaurant
absolutely that kitchen is the heart of
the restaurant when that's hurt it's
like a clogged artery you're gonna have
a big problem
with so much of the kitchen equipment
not working it's almost impossible for
the chefs to do their jobs and their
frustration has been felt by the rest of
the staff where's my uh Portofino
they're coming but don't keep asking for
them don't ask for them one more
time when there's a chaotic night here I
have Robert screaming when the fishes
are ready that's when they're gonna come
out he's an excellent chef but he's
crazy take them take this out
gotta keep asking for the food
drink
[Music]
it's only business I think they said
that in The Godfather I charge
my doctor trust me he earns enough yeah
it's like a little meeting place here a
little meeting place yeah shame no one's
spending money
the combination of Peter spending a
great deal of money on himself and
giving away free meals has put the
family business in jeopardy
and brought a debt collector to the door
[Music]
yeah he'd like no not right now I know
buddy no no no no no no no as soon as
you got a minute yeah okay as soon as
you got a minute
go yourself get the out of
here
you want to hit me put your hands on me
I'll let you do it first listen guys
you ain't got me scared all right you
ain't got me scared don't walk
up on me
now wasn't the time
after Peter's brush with an overzealous
debt collector Gordon checks in with his
sister restaurant owner Tina I know I've
just arrived but
me how do you manage oh I'm
motivated by all the nice people that
come into visit me but other than that
I'm having a breakdown tell me your
biggest frustration what's the one big
issue that you have from the kitchen to
my brother just it seems like it's only
like a free-for-all like everyone's just
doing what they want I get so
exasperated sometimes so stressed out
that I want to cry or commit bloody
murder but does Peter play upon in the
financial side he'll take his paycheck
but not come in I come in and I'll
they'll tell me oh Peter took 200.
[Music]
like
like I didn't even break even
for the day and he took money you can't
do that
how long can you continue functioning
like this with this how much longer and
I can't I can't do it either I would
sooner sell the business I'm not a
martyr I feel like I'm doing it on my
own and that's the part about it I
resent it's not fair if this doesn't
work you know what's at stake in terms
of you know how much would you lose my
house your house
this is crazy because the true
definition of a family business is every
member of that family working within to
make it successful not one person
carrying the burden
I know
[Music]
it's day three and time for Gordon to
give the family A much needed wake-up
call
this business was set up 17 years ago as
a family business yes yes today we're
going to renew that commitment we're
going to make it more family than ever
before this is what we're gonna do you
yeah with your father I'm gonna go and
run the kitchen
you're gonna cook
hey
I want you to go and work in that
kitchen and just experience what it's
like behind that line and work with your
dad you like food you certainly eat
enough of it here Tina you're going to
run the dining room with your mum okay
get in the kitchen and get familiar with
what's going on Peter never seen cook
but I never seen them boil an egg
find it
Peter's like one of those guys he eats
out a lot so he assumes he knows about
cooking in restaurants he has no clue
about the kitchen hello
well Peter and his father are settling
into the kitchen why is this Burning
don't go lower welcome to
Gordon is packing the dining room with
hungry customers
come on do me a favor make me an
espresso please
don't make it yourself I just want my
mother get me espresso and I'm ready
espresso
is he always like this yeah huh is he my
God if my dad and my brother were the
chefs I think there'd be a mass murder
in here I have an order
[Music]
the first order's in I need black olives
and artichokes right underneath here
could someone set the us up oh hold on
now is them that didn't set you up
properly I'm having a meltdown here are
we ready to order do you need a few
minutes can I have a working
oven those are the ones I wanted already
that clams and the soup
what the is that this is a
clusterfuff back here Angela table seven
please
where's the salmon where's my lemon
we're shouting for lemons and look
there's a box of lemons here I
need clean spoons I need clean spoons I
need chicken I need chicken what's that
in front of your eyes oh okay
Peter is he's a 250 pound spoiled baby
holy they two didn't get distracted
no you have to get them out what do you
want me to do I can do it at the moment
okay let's put the cat amongst the
pigeons Peter's now getting a taste of
his own medicine he's now seen how
difficult it is to cook in that kitchen
with nothing that works so this is
embarrassing because this should have
been a family close-knit type run
restaurant it's an hour into lunch
service and there's still no food coming
out of the kitchen
I don't know I'm looking for a corner to
hide somewhere would someone get me Tina
please I need orange juice you want Tina
to stop now and get you a glass of
orange juice do I have anybody that can
help me look at orange juice
yourself what I beg your pardon
take it easy take it easy killer
I want to see what big boys made of come
on
yeah let's go big boy relax
finally someone told them listen buddy
don't act like you're you're the king
over here because you got nothing you
get the out of it out Robert back
on here please yeah let's go God
unbelievable
now Gordon has proved his point about
the inadequate kitchen he realizes that
he has to do something drastic to get
the restaurant ready to be relaunched
Gordon did you know attack Peter in the
right way because he saw him as being
you know a big shot a guy trying to act
like a big shot just do me a favor oh
yeah we go out we're gonna get some
fresh air or yeah go get a
manicure polish your wheels or do
something
[Music]
it's day four and although Peter's
attitude to work has been a
disappointment Gordon has no choice but
to introduce the first phase of his
transformation plan right today is a new
beginning a new chapter for Peter's
restaurant yes yes the one thing that
really needs to take place here is
commitment
we're going to implement changes
follow me please yeah through the
kitchen
[Music]
welcome to your new kitchen
oh my God
oh man holy
bro have a look I'll have a look Gordon
brought in a team of kitchen Specialists
who worked all night to give this
restaurant something it's sorely needed
a proper kitchen every oven is working
oh my God foreign
[Music]
plates stoves ovens mats I can't believe
it I knew double fridge as well oh my
God what guess the proper working fridge
yes what a kitchen I think we were all
starting to lose steam here and give up
and and he he brought us back to uh a
sunny day
your new kingdom this is really a good
thing now I can really have a real
kitchen where I can actually do things
the right way I've invested in this
now I want to see you with opportunity
comes responsibility and I think that's
what Gordon was trying to point out you
know what I've given you what you asked
for now you're responsible to use it
respectfully
it's time for
time for to good use as Gordon starts to
change the menu there we go I want to
focus on Family Style Dining we're going
to be making simple stunning classic
Italian foods
lasagna I'm very excited tonight to cook
with Gordon definitely an honor to cook
with someone like him
I fell into a bit of a rut culinarily
and now that Gordon's giving me this new
menu to work with it's a revitalizing
kind of feeling you know
let's go Gordon introduces a new family
style menu that will make pizza's
restaurant stand out from the
competition there's what six seven
Italian restaurants out there in Babylon
one thing
that can separate this restaurant from
the others is running this like a true
Family Restaurant Gordon came about the
idea of family style which I think is an
exceptional idea we needed something to
help us stand out
for tonight's dinner service The Parsley
covered ravioli and the cold crab cakes
have been replaced by fresh homemade
family style dishes such as Lobster
ravioli the penne lasagna grilled flank
steak kabalini and norquita and then
porchetta which is beautiful you know
these are dishes that are popular this
is now a time for you to sort of really
seriously start getting that message out
there it's so simple
okay guys I've got a a big big big
launch yeah big time
oh man
with a brand new kitchen a redesigned
menu and a new approach that reaches out
to families the restaurant is ready for
its big relaunch let's do it
[Music]
with the doors about to open Gordon
gathers the staff for a last minute pep
talk okay
tonight is a critical crucial night are
you with us or you I'm just waiting for
okay but we're right really busy right
now
once again Peter has a debt collector on
his doorstep
well you are interfere that's what I'm
saying go the way
here
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy this guy come on you
fake gangster you
you're a you're
embarrassing me this guy go inside
relax relax
relax relax come on come on you scumbag
get it off guys
right now
hey come on people take it easy come in
here
come here instead of Five Guys to his
house right now Jeremy and guys are on
their way right now who the is it
give me a sandwich
it's the last that's coming in
this place you're getting
hot-headed
no so what do you mean relaxed
calm down calm down calm down hey
I told him to get out are you okay they
fight a lot you know these things happen
relax relax relax relax
let's see outside two seconds walk fresh
air come on with me let's go
what's going on what happened
don't conduct that in my business no no
you're right that's first of all second
of all I didn't like the way he spoke to
you he's going to speak
relax relax relax
big deep breath yeah
I'm here to help
the row has wasted crucial preparation
time now Gordon urgently needs to get
Peter and the staff focused on tonight's
relaunch
big big night I mean a seriously big
night yeah a new menu new Family Style
Dining new attitude this could be the
big turning point for this restaurant
use this opportunity to show off how
good we can be
good luck
there's excitement in the restaurant
about the new menu
through the fish it's excellent
I like the idea but back in the kitchen
it's up to the chefs to deliver
tables are all ordering family style now
all of a sudden we're working with all
this new stuff
it's like alien may I have a cranberry
juice salsa and cranberry
actually you know what you have
pineapple juice yeah give me pineapple
juice with a lot of ice and a splash of
cranberry it's good for my sugar
it's one hour into dinner service and
the restaurant has not been this full
for seven years let's set this up for 14
right now come on come on come on
right now they've got a 14 top just
arrived and this is a true test now
because family style should make their
life a lot easier or it can go 10
something be a disaster it's so busy
Tina Tina you have a drought lysinger
Peter as an owner he should step up to
you know what move his ass a little bit
more because he's in la la land I don't
know where to go you know this table
right here yeah bring him an appetizer
too that's cool all right
but when Peter does decide to lend a
hand not hungry man instead of serving
the baked clams you gotta walk back here
anybody got a fork quite honestly go
ahead and see me eating I don't want to
get yelled at he decides to eat them
oh man
excuse me Peter I gotta ask you for one
favor delicious
Robert what what the is going on
here nothing you're hungry yeah off
yeah go and look at your stomach in the
window let's go yeah we need another
dozen day clams one of yours went out
come on still waiting on my baked clams
all right I'll take care of you with
that I'll bring us more
guys should I come should I come back
next week for the baked clam should I go
down the block for the other restaurant
I promise you you'll have it
okay I thought he was filling up new
menu new kitchen new Family Style Dining
but Peter it's liking Sam right now no
honey I'll take a cappuccino if you can
make me with two equals please it was
really difficult I mean you know in my
legs hurt my toilet it was harder than
the gym it was really hotter than the
gym when Gordon puts the pressure on
Peter they waited 50 minutes for the
clams Peter takes it out on his
stuff
is she doing
no one came to your table Yeah Nicole
are you kidding me you can go to these
people's table I wasn't supposed to be
my table I don't care what it was
supposed to be taking right now right
now he was yelling at me in front of my
customers for things that I didn't do
wasn't supposed to be my table imagine
this it's hard for him to you know
realize that he did something wrong so
he takes it out on everybody else get
them one bottle on me right now for all
your Comedy of Errors tonight
thank you so you cost me a bottle of
wine
please I don't know why Peter's temper
is like that
I mean he's in everybody's way everybody
else just brushes it off but I guess I
just take it a little personal when he's
screaming at me in front of my table so
what the is going on with A7 and
everything what's my table is excessive
to me like oh wow he's being hard on you
blah blah blah
how can I be a hard person to talk to
that's ridiculous
talk to me like that kid how could you
cry she was like a machine gun she just
started shooting all this stuff out she
looked like she was having some sort of
uh meltdown I don't make
you're embarrassing me
just turn it down a bit just hey oh my
God I never seen something like this
[Music]
thank you very much thank you thank you
with over 200 satisfied customers the
relaunch is a success
in spite of bitter this place was a
success and is now pissed through your
hands
well it is what it it is what it is
you've neglected it I understand but
right now we're not in a situation
money-wise to fix it well me what's
the time
what do you think it says your
little Salon to get your massage and get
fed
you're walking around this place
with a bowl of food in your hand
eating away
[Music]
that's not how I run my business
I'm getting a headache
I don't think you've seen him day's work
for 20 years yeah I I've had my
own personal problems we all have
problems problem problem problem
you're no different let's
start working at the problem what's the
problem what's the problem you that's
where I'm starting excuse me
[Music]
hey nuts this guy you're right
I'm nuts because you've got
all to worry about right now have you
listen to me I'm listening
listen to me you sound like you're out
the Godfather yeah what the
is going on here
you're the only here right now
is not pulling their weight and that's
not good enough
[Music]
I think this place will run better
without you
foreign
I think this place will run better
without you
I I I disagree you disagree I'll own
certain problems and I'll take
responsibility for a lot of things that
was about as convincing as a
person I'm here
[Applause]
[Music]
I need two minutes with you on your own
you guys I'll see in the morning
I love him
tonight go home and come back tomorrow
morning and think about what are you
going to put back into the business
tomorrow think about it
and make sure it's good because
I'm gonna be here to make sure you do it
I'm never speechless I don't know what
to say
[Music]
I'm I'm like I'm a little hurt
what I'm seeing now is
he said to me everything all these
people wanted to say to me and haven't
so maybe Gordon's right you know what
I'm not gonna say maybe Gordon's right
Gordon is right
I'm committed I'll be back and I'll do
what he says it's for the good of the
business and in the end this place is me
this place is me this is me this is what
I do so I gotta make it work
[Music]
to Gordon's amazement the next morning
he found Peter on the phone calling to
fix the walk-in fridge we need our
walk-in box fixed leaking here there's
like obviously there's rain water I want
you to come here and do whatever it
needs to have done I'm really amazed
that Peter is taking the initiative and
putting the new Walking boxing and to go
with the brand new kitchen Robert and
John have a new attitude I'm very
excited I think everything's going so
well
[Music]
and the Family Style Dining is a huge
hit with customers
I haven't had family style in uh down
here
with Word of Mouth spreading prophets
are soaring at the end of the night we
made more money we made more money this
way it's unbelievable as soon as they
calm down I'll show you
[Music]
to the local community
first ever Babylon family day
[Music]
help yourself food is good really good
this is a huge great start to to push
the new Family theme
come and my family will serve yours
[Music]
complete Peter sided the restaurant
needed one more thing
the father May the blessing of almighty
God the Father the Son the holy spirit
this was a rebirth so it needed its
blessing
I got a thing about Hogan's father thank
you so much
in the weeks ahead Peter was more
helpful yeah I'll get some extra plates
too okay he made amends with Nicole I'm
sorry I'm sorry all right my priorities
were mixed up instead of trying to be
like you know the boss I'm gonna be a
team player here and whatever needs to
be done I'm gonna do I'm gonna jump in
I'm gonna ask people if they need help
with things there you go enjoy
and even provided Tina with the help she
needed I mean I'm thrilled I even think
Peter will do his part I really do think
he's going to keep his commitment I'm
sorry I love you I love you too
foreign
let's just confirm one thing shall we
've got a taste of how good this
restaurant can be absolutely and just
comparing to what I experienced the
first time I arrived here tonight the
difference was night and day
before Gordon got here this place was
nose diving the man
reinvented my restaurant I think now
he's given us all our spark back if you
cannot make this work you're mad you've
got a potential gold mine here that can
make every one of you successfully
rich
we are definitely on our way to success
here now we have to take the ball and
run with it thank you for the commitment
yeah yeah we've been giving all the help
in the world Farmers to shine and we got
what we need
and I'm ready to do it
all of Gordon's ideas stemmed to keep
this restaurant synonymous with family
we all love each other so that's my main
ingredient now for the restaurant and I
think that's so important three thousand
dollars
for extra material
take care
I really fell in love with him my first
son is going to be named after Gordon
Gordon Ramsay Pellegrino and Gordon
really brought our family much closer
together hi buddy yes thank you
but this time they can stay together and
commit to this question it will be
successful but stop the fighting
[Music]